it's taken far too long to get a black
widow solo movie
it took waiting out a real world
pandemic and the characters on-screen
death in avengers end game
but finally black widow is here confused
about some of the plot's twists and
turns
here are the biggest unanswered
questions we have about black widow
early in black widow director kate
shortland uses some clever misdirection
we're led to believe that we're about to
get a showdown between natasha and
secretary ross's men
in an office building when in fact the
black widow is already long gone
on a ferry headed for a safe house in
norway while it likely has nothing to do
with the overall story of either black
widow or the mcu
it's interesting that norway is
natasha's destination
considering who else may be in the
country when she arrives the events of
black widow are set during 2016's
captain america civil war
between tony stark's confrontation with
nat after the airport battle
and the rescue of the anti-registration
heroes from the raft
what's interesting is that 2017's thor
ragnarok also takes place during the
events of civil war
and in the beginning of ragnarok we
learn odin has escaped loki's magic
and is waiting in norway for his sons to
arrive that isn't in norway for very
long
it's during her first night in the safe
house as she's attacked by taskmaster
and soon afterwards she heads for
budapest but it's at least possible she
was in norway at the same time as odin
perhaps even on the same day as his
death
one of the more mysterious characters of
black widow is mason
it's mason who secures that safe house
for her along with a chopper to rescue
alexi from prison
and even a quinjet there's some palpable
sexual tension between mason and that
you get the sense either they have a
romantic past or they've been circling
each other
flirtatiously for a long time this
probably has a lot to do with why mason
is willing to continue supplying that
even though secretary russ is forcing
him into a corner
while we don't get a lot of details
about mason in black widow
it's possible we've met a relative in
the comics mason is better known as rick
mason
aka the agent his father is phineas
mason the tinkerer
a tech genius known for supplying super
villains with their gadgets
while he's never referred to as a
tinkerer on screen we meet
phineas mason in 2017 spider-man
homecoming
working for the vulture when we first
meet alexi in 1995 he's clearly already
an adept storyteller
considering he's been hiding his family
from the authorities for years
stupid he's still telling stories just
before nat and elena's bring him from
prison
in particular he enjoys regarding his
fellow prisoners about his supposedly
epic battles
with captain america the one prisoner
brave enough to point
out that steve rogers was still frozen
at the bottom of the ocean when alexi
was supposed to be fighting him
pays for it by losing the use of his
hand in spite of alexi's obvious lies
he still seems to think he and captain
america have some kind of history
like they did in the comics one of the
first things he does after being sprung
from prison
is to ask nat whether or not steve
rogers ever asked about him
is it possible he actually does have
some kind of history with captain
america
on one hand with all the mysteries
surrounding steve rogers journey to the
past at the end of avengers ends game
and the changing story about whether
that takes place in another timeline or
the prime one
could he and a time travelling steve
rogers have clashed at some point
on the other hand could red guardian be
using some poetic license with a battle
that took place not with steve rogers
but another super soldier
perhaps isaiah bradley or someone like
him it's been clear ever since her
interrogation of loki and the avengers
that the innocent lives natasha took
while working for the red room still
haunt her
but while we don't hear much about it
once the scene is over
it seems likely nat and her sister took
a lot more innocent lives
rescuing their adoptive father from
prison while defending herself from the
prison gods elena unintentionally
triggers an avalanche
nathan alexi narrowly avoid being swept
away by the avalanche
but we never learn the fate of the
prisons inmates or guards
considering the severity of the
avalanche and the fact that the heroes
were the only ones have a helicopter
they could use to get away
it seems pretty likely most if not all
were buried beneath it and killed
and strangely this is never mentioned
neither nat
elena nor alexi betray any kind of
regret over what happens
there are a lot of differences between
the taskmaster of black widow
and the villain of the source material
including gender
but one thing that remains the same is
their abilities in both the comics and
the movies taskmaster can instantly
perform any martial task
they see performed by combat experts in
the film we see taskmaster can use a bow
and arrow like hawkeye
a shield like captain america and even
claws like black panther
we also see taskmaster using a sword the
thing is
at this point in the mcu we haven't seen
any major heroes or villains using
swords
at least none taskmaster would have
access to recordings of
of course it isn't like you have to be a
superhero or villain to use a sword
still almost all the other forms of
martial combat we see taskmaster use
come from some major hero it could be
that this is foreshadowing for the
upcoming eternals
which will include the premiere of the
ebony blade wielding black knight
played by kit harrington of course
another marvel hero famous for wielding
swords as a vampire hunter blade
whom a herschler ali is set to play we
know for a fact parts of eternals will
be set in the mcu's past
and it's possible part of blade could be
as well if recordings of either heroes
exist it could explain taskmaster's own
skill with a blade
we get teased with the possibility of
learning about natasha's birth parents
toward the end of black widow
dracor acts as if he's going to give nat
her mother's name
then cruelly says only that a headstone
reads unknown
shortly before her death in end game nag
gets the tiniest of crumbs from the red
skull
he calls her natasha daughter of ivan
and moments later we learned that until
the name came out of the skull's mouth
nata didn't know so much as his first
name much less his last
all she's able to learn from molina is
that the story she was told about her
mother abandoning her was a lie
sadly with nat dying in end game it
seems unlikely we'll ever learn anything
about her birth parents
since elaine europe is set to continue
to be a part of the mcu going forward
it could be that she'll investigate
further but would assume she'd be much
more interested in learning about her
own origins
and maybe finally getting to the bottom
of the pose
why do you always do that thing what
thing the pose
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser we don't actually see much of
drakov before the end of the film
but if one thing is clear the guy likes
to brag with what he thinks is a
helpless natasha
dracorf opens up about his global
network of mind-controlled widows
and the kind of power they give him the
scene feels a lot like the ai zola
bringing steven that up to speed on
hydra
and bucky and captain america the winter
soldier but with one exception
we never get any solid idea of exactly
what the widows have done
veykorv gives some very broad strokes
about what he can do with the widows
he makes the kind of bose you'd expect
that with them he can topple governments
he can destroy economies and so on
and it's clear that yes for a while now
the emissaries of the red room have
spilled plenty of blood
but we never learn exactly what kind of
power moves dracorv has made with the
widows
as he toppled governments as he
destroyed economies exactly how does the
world of the mcu look different because
of what he's made his widows do
it turns out all the widows including
that have been conditioned to be enabled
to directly attack dracorf
while in range of his pheromones that
pretends to be surprised by this but we
learned she and molina worked it out
earlier
molina tells her that she will need to
completely sever a nerve connected to
her olfactory system
essentially losing her sense of smell to
bypass draekorv's pheromones
nat tries to get dracov to do it himself
by provoking him into beating her
but when he can't finish the job she
does it for him so does this mean mata's
completely without a sense of smell for
the rest of her life
she painfully resets her broken nose
after dracov escapes
but suffering a nose sounds fairly well
permanent
it doesn't sound like something that
could be corrected by resetting a broken
nose
by the end of black widow all of the
surviving widows are freed from
draekorv's controller
before leaving drakov's office nat
downloads the data about other widows
across the globe
and she hands it off to elena alexey
molina and elena leave with all the
widows including taskmaster
so what are the widows and the rest of
nat's found family doing now
in most likelihood they spent some time
locating and liberating the rest of
dracor's widows
but the present day mcu is set in 2023
seven or so years after black widow we
know from the post-credits scene that
elena is working for contessa valentina
allegra defontaine
aka val don't call me that copy
val who we were introduced to in the
falcon and the winter soldier
seems like she would certainly love to
get the rest of the widows on her
payroll
but that doesn't mean the widows would
feel the same perhaps some went to work
for val
some became freelancers and maybe others
did their best to build
normal lives then there's the question
of what happened to alexi and molina
they clearly still share a mutual
attraction so there's a decent chance
there are a couple
as for what else they're up to
considering their former employers they
probably don't have a ton of moral
scruplers regarding who they do
and don't work for they might have found
the place working for val as well
for fans of marvel's trademark post
credit scenes black widow doesn't
disappoint
it's clear elena has been working for
val for a while and the contessa has
come to give elena her next target
who she refers to as the man responsible
for your sister's death
in other words clint barton anyone who's
seen avengers endgame knows saint barton
is responsible for natasha's demise
is a pretty limited and obviously
manipulative interpretation
of natasha's sacrifice regardless what's
most intriguing here is a question of
why val wants hawkeye dead
without knowing more about val and her
agenda the most obvious answer is that
it has something to do with barton's
vigilante activities as ronin
in the years between the events of
avengers infinity war and
endgame it could be that the government
now sees him as a wild card
and wants him taken out quietly or it
could be that the carnage he caused in
the global
crime community made the wrong people
angry it seems likely we'll have to wait
until the release of disney plus as
hawkeye to know for sure
the fans hoping that the mcu is building
its own big screen thunderbolts a marvel
comics team composed of mostly either
reformed villains or heroes with
criminal past
the post-credits scene of black widow
offers some promising teasers
the very fact that val appears in the
scene as a hint she's introduced in the
falcon and the winter soldier
a series which had long been rumored to
build the foundation for the
thunderbolts entry
into the mcu along with featuring bucky
and zemo both of whom have fronted their
own versions of the thunderbolts in the
comics
the series sees john walker recruited by
val and
considering walker's actions in the
series he certainly rates us a guy who
could use some redemption
val's meeting with elena can only add
more fuel to the speculation
not only would an assassin like elena be
a perfect fit for an mcu thunderbolt but
she's tasked with taking out hawkeye
yet another character who leads his own
thunderbolts team in the comics
we'll have to wait and see obviously but
the more val shows up the more likely it
seems she's planting seeds for a team
that isn't quite as clean-cut as the
avengers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
black widow are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one